[Music]
an uneasy peace between china and taiwan
has existed for more than 70 years
that peace is now under unusual strain
taiwan is a self-governed island of 24
million people with a thriving democracy
but the chinese communist party claims
that it's part of china
which is why when nancy pelosi the
speaker of america's house of
representatives visited taiwan
china flexed its military muscles
a real collapse in trust and it's a
really dangerous moment
tensions are high
the question is
will it lead to war
it's really striking out the last few
years in places like washington other
capitals there is a new sense of urgency
about how soon chinese communist leaders
particularly xi jinping could feel they
have no choice but to use force in some
way to take taiwan back war over taiwan
cannot possibly be inevitable if you're
chinese and you think you can do it
another way you've got to want to do it
without fighting because it would be
unbelievably costly to so much that
china has built up over the last decades
of economic prosperity it would also be
unimaginably dangerous if you think the
ukraine crisis is scary remember that
joe biden made clear on day one that
american soldiers were never going to
fight russian soldiers that's not the
case in taiwan there are plenty of
realistic scenarios that on day one of a
taiwan war the american military would
have to sink chinese ships as they tried
to invade taiwan that the chinese air
force might have to bomb american
fighter jets sitting in japanese air
force bases that is very very close to a
regional if not a world war and they're
nuclear superpowers it should be utterly
unthinkable why is it not unthinkable
because if you're the leader of the
chinese communist party and you look at
taiwan the problem that you have is that
time works in two very different ways
with every passing year china's military
gets stronger and the taiwanese military
gets weaker and china's ability to keep
america at bay looks more impressive so
that could be a reason to be patient
think well why rush why take a risk of a
war that we could lose but the passage
of time also works another way which is
with every passing year hearts and minds
the people of taiwan particularly young
people in taiwan they become less and
less interested in being run from
beijing by the communist party fewer and
fewer taiwanese think of themselves as
chinese in any meaningful sense there
are worst case scenarios where china
could feel it had no choice but to stop
taiwan from declaring independence or
drifting away where xi jinping a man
with a very strong sense of his own
destiny could feel i have to do this
before i step down and that really
worries uh leaders and generals in the
west i started an american official who
studied this
this crisis for years and he said the
problem is we've never seen this level
of military build up this level of
nationalism not end in a conflict we
shouldn't pretend that every american
has strong views about the future of
taiwan but in certain key places above
all congress in washington democrats and
republicans who don't agree on much they
agree that taiwan is a plucky
pro-american pro-western democracy that
deserves to be protected from the
communist bully next door and that's a
very powerful bipartisan message and
there is there's pressure on the
administration to do more to help taiwan
pressure that china sees as a hostile
offensive move and so the american
foreign policy elite the american
political classes they are more
pro-taiwan than we've seen for a very
long time and that is a very
destabilizing situation here's the
danger taiwanese public opinion
is remarkably calm in the face of this
crisis and one of the things we've heard
during the nancy pelosi visit is you
know why is the western media so up in
arms about this uh you know we taiwanese
are so calm we don't get fussed about
these attacks china makes too much money
uh in taiwan to ever do something stupid
like start a war that's a really common
line to hear in taiwan
but actually there are plenty of people
in america who think that it's really
possible that these threats are real and
that they could have to fight a war
there is no way that americans can care
more about taiwan's safety than the
taiwanese do so if there is a sense in
america that taiwanese public opinion is
actually complacent and that young
taiwanese are just not interested in
looking after themselves in joining the
army in doing real national service then
i think you could see support for taiwan
start to waver i am really struck in my
time as a china correspondent you know
it used to be that grown-up
sophisticated ambassadors senior
officials in governments like the
american government who had access to
the most classified intelligence if you
ask them could there be a war over
taiwan
not that long ago the kind of
sophisticated
knowing thing to say was of course not
it's unthinkable you know the stakes are
too high china knows it's too dangerous
and now i hear very different messages
it's maybe and maybe quite soon maybe
before the end of this decade and
there's a real soberness about uh how
dangerous the stakes are and how the two
sides are absolutely convinced that the
status quo is being undermined by the
other there is a real collapse in trust
and it's a really dangerous moment
i'm david rennie beijing buruchi for the
economist if you'd like to read more of
our coverage of china and taiwan please
click the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe